[Music]  it seems like from the moment you're  born people think they got you all  figured out based on how you look how  you talk where you're from but it's not  that simple especially when it comes to  these complex i'm fer de net you look at  me and think big you think scary you  think well at least he's not in a china  shop oh no baby steps baby steps  [Music]  take me back to you and I've not seen  before in feels and so long  No  [Music]  I'm not a fighting bull you don't need  to be a fighting bull you just have to  look like a fighting noise you see that  barrel over there batshit to pieces but  hey what else you gonna hit it with  ready  [Music]  sorry I almost killed you in the studio  that brought you shredded kung fu panda  and Madagascar hi I'm Jorge beer miss my  best friend Harold Hutchins we just meet  comics and try to make each other laugh  if this old guy